- Did you get, I'm asking everyone,
did you get the same gift
from Tom Hanks at the end?
- Okay, listen.
I was so happy you didn't
know what it was either.
- No!
- 'Cause I was strugglin'.
- But I love that this is
coming out here.
- Here.
On a public forum.
- I know!
- My favorite!
- How dare we not know
- I know!
- what Sir Tom Hanks gave us as a gift!
It's our fault.
- I know!
- It's our fault, actually.
- It's so funny!
- It's either a riding,
like something to ride
a horse, or something--
(laughing boisterously)
- I am so excited about the guesses!
- Yes, it is the equestrian's companion.
- It is!
- Yes.
I realize now.
- Or you put a paper in it.
I don't know!
It's one or the other.
- I think it's more like
loose-leafed papers.
- This is just--
- Or tobacco.
(laughing)
- This is the greatest
quest I've ever been on.
Matthew and Susan were both telling us
that you gave the most awesome wrap gift.
They were like, "It's so beautiful!
"It's leather.
"It's inscribed.
"It's so beautiful."
- It's got the name on it, yeah.
- Yes, and they were like, we
just don't know what it is!
- Know what it is.
(laughing)
- And you're Tom Hanks so
they were too afraid to ask!
- Here's what it is.
When you show up to work on a movie,
you have a copy of the
pages that you're...
They're called sides--
- Sides, yeah.
- The script pages that
you're shooting that day,
and the call sheet,
so everybody knows
exactly what you're doing.
They are leather holders for those sides.
And there's a little pen,
and you can keep notes on it.
- That's very thoughtful!
- I've used it on complicated days,
'cause you need to know.
And the fact that neither Susan
nor Matthew knew what they were--
- No, but the fact that there were two--
- Are these people professional actors?
I don't understand.
- No, no!
It's because they were like,
it's so beautiful, but...
She even said, "I don't know.
"Some sort of saddle." (laughing)
I don't know what she said.
- Use it as a coin purse!
I don't care!
- But it was funny though,
because then they're gonna
figure it out though.
And it makes perfect sense.
It's the most perfect wrap gift.
- It's a tool.
- It's beautiful.
Now they know.
- Now they know.
- The more you know.
- So, take it down from the shelf,
take it out of its shrink wrap,
and use the damn things,
for cryin' out loud.